mateo gil et gilles alberti bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
ce matin sur rtl france alors le
dénouement est il proche selon vous les
italiens ont-ils enfants à parvenir à se
mettre d'accord sur le nom du prochain
président de la république
les choses évoluent très rapidement et
sont tous où il ya eu des évolutions
pendant la nuit effectivement les
témoignages que vous avez diffusé tout à
l'heure on remonte à allières ce matin
on a vu qu'il y avait apparemment une
détermination de la part des forces du
centre droite 2
votez le nord de marjah à la liberté
elisabetta par dong alberti casey de
lahti c'est à dire la présidente
l'actuelle présidente du sénat qui est
de toute façon la deuxième figure
institutionnelle de l'état italien comme
en france
et cette dame qui est perçu pour une
bonne partie des parlementaires comme
une figure institutionnels donc en tout
cas à mesure de garder les distances
entre les forces politiques si elle est
élue au sommet de l'état ne plaît pas
malgré tout aussi à d'autres
parlementaires notamment ceux de gauche
que ce matin on dit que l trophy
considéré que sa figure était plutôt
divisive est pas en mesure de rassembler
les parlementaires et le pays en italie
la fonction présidentielle et
prestigieuses mais largement
protocolaires finalement le principal
enjeu de cette élection c'est de garder
mario draghi à la tête du conseil
ben ce n'est pas vraiment seulement
honorifique eu le rôle du chef de l'état
surtout parce que oui la constitution
lui attribue des pouvoirs limités mais
dans les dernières années dernières
vingt ans
on a vu que finalement le chef de l'état
à travers une position en tout cas de
deux
régions comme disent les anglais à
participer finalement la constitution
des gouvernements surtout dans le choix
du timing des comédiens des candidats
pour recouvrir le rôle de premier
ministre ou bien un rappelant à l'ordre
un petit peu les forces politiques qui a
peut-être trouvé pas d'accord au sein du
parlement non cash et c'est vrai que sur
le papier le président de la république
et reste quelque chose une figure 13
on dira représentative mais dans les
faits il est devenu un acteur aussi de
la politique italienne et aussi de la
politique internationale de l'italie
comme on a pu voir aussi à l'occasion
justement des relations entre emmanuelle
de la crau et celle du retard et là ces
derniers mois
laisse plutôt actuellement se tiennent à
bulletin secret ce qui permet de
conserver l'anonymat est ce qu'il
faudrait finalement rendre votre
transparent pour justement éviter cette
relativité ou mon élection
ben oui ce serait sans doute quelque
chose de deux souhaitable après et il
faut considérer que du de france c'est
quelque chose de pré-mise en temps ce
système d'élection mais il ne faut pas
oublier que l'italie est à une
démocratie parlementaire et donc le
parlement a le rôle clé à l'intérieur de
la quittera le délai de l'intérieur de
la structure institutionnelle de l'état
donc même si on avait la contenir le
vote
en clair disons il y aurait la
possibilité en tout cas d'avoir
plusieurs élections parce que c'est
voilà la constitution voulue que une
majorité importante départs volontaires
pour un accord sur le nom du président
justement parce que le président
présente l unité nationale et donc je
pense qu'il y aurait quand même un beau
coup de négociation derrière et puis
n'oublions pas en tout cas que c'est un
processus démocratique et là il est un
peu ralentie par l'écho vite vous avez
vu peut-être dans les images qu'il y
avait grande cabine
alors centre de la chambre des députés
italienne et bien si chaque opération et
on y apprend plus de temps parce qu'il
faut se méfier aussi désinfecter lisons
les urnes etc et en plus jusqu'à hier on
faisait seulement une vote une votation
par jour aujourd'hui la dernière à qui
on a affaire à des tirs aujourd'hui à la
l'italique donc qui connaîtra peut-être
aujourd'hui le nom de son futur
président en tout cas merci beaucoup
matteo à gilles alberti d'avoir répondu
à nos questions je rappelle que vous
êtes journaliste pour le site de films
media.com